los abogados de novak djokovic durante
el fin de semana han presentado
documentos ante la corte federal con los
que buscan que el tenista de 34 años
pueda disputar el abierto de australia
que empieza el lunes 17 de enero en tan
solo una semana según la defensa
djokovic contaba con una visa sin
condiciones aprobada desde el 18 de
noviembre y que además tenía una
extensión médica expedida por la entidad
tenis australia y fue revisada por dos
paneles médicos uno independiente y otro
del gobierno del estado de victoria la
extensión médica de acuerdo con el
documento presentado por los abogados se
basó en el hecho de que el deportista
había dado positivo para kobe 19 en una
prueba pcr el 16 de diciembre y que en
las 72 horas previas no había presentado
síntomas sin embargo el gobierno federal
ha insistido en que la expedición de
visas es un proceso automatizado y que
cada viajero a su llegada deben proveer
los documentos que prueben el estado de
vacunación o la extensión médica de ser
deportado a djokovic se le podría
prohibir el ingreso australia hasta por
tres años la decisión está en manos del
juez del circuito federal anthony quien
lee por otro lado la tenista checa de 38
años renata voracova fue deportada tras
haber ingresado a australia con una
extensión médica luego de haberse
recuperado de conil 19 voracova quien
había entrado al país el mes pasado y
kim ya estaba jugando un torneo de
entrenamiento llegó en la noche del
sábado hacia dubai pues a diferencia de
djokovic decidió no apelar la decisión
ante la corte